[Music]
the Dirty Jobs crew and I were called to
a little town in Colorado called Craig
it's only a couple dozen square miles
it's in the Rockies and the job in
question was sheep rancher my role on
the show for those of you who haven't
seen it's pretty simple I'm an
apprentice and I work with the people
who actually do the jobs in question and
my responsibilities are to simply try
and keep up and give an honest account
of what it's like to be these people for
one day in their life job in question
herding sheep great we go to Craig and
we check into a hotel and I realized the
next day that castration is going to be
an absolute part of this work so
normally I never do any research at all
but this is a touchy subject and I work
for the Discovery Channel and we want to
portray accurately whatever it is we do
and we certainly want to do it with a
lot of respect for the animals so I call
the Humane Society and I say look I'm
gonna be castrating some lamps can you
tell me the deal and they're like yeah
it's pretty straightforward they use a
band basically a rubber band like this a
little smaller this one was actually
around the playing cards I got yesterday
but it had a certain familiarity to it
and I said well what exactly is the
process and they said the band is
applied to the tail tightly and then
another band is applied to the scrotum
tightly blood flow is slowly [ __ ] a
week later the parts in question fall
off great got it okay I call the SPCA to
confirm this they confirm it I also call
PETA just for fun and they don't like it
but they confirm it okay that's
basically how you do it so the next day
I go out and I'm given a horse and we go
get the Lambs and we take them to a pen
that we built and we go about the
business of animal husbandry Melanie is
the wife of Albert Albert's the shepherd
in question Melanie picks up the lamb
two hands one hand on both legs and the
right likewise on the left lamb goes on
the post she opens another
all right great Albert goes in I follow
Albert the crews around
I always watch the process done the
first time before I try it being an
apprentice you know you do that
Albert reaches in his pocket to pull out
you know this black rubber band but what
comes out instead is a knife and I'm
like that's not rubber at all you know
and and he kind of flicked it open in a
way that caught the Sun that was just
coming over the Rockies it was very uh
it was it was it was impressive in the
space of about two seconds Albert had
the knife between the cartilage of the
tail right next to the butt of the lamb
and very quickly the tail was gone and
in the bucket that I was holding a
second later with a big thumb and a well
calloused forefinger he had the scrotum
firmly in his grasp and he pulled it
toward him like so and he took the knife
and he put it on the tip now you think
you know what's coming Michael you don't
okay
he snips it throws the tip over his
shoulder and then grabs the scrotum and
pushes it upward and then his head dips
down obscuring my view but what I hear
is a slurping sound and a noise that
sounds like velcro being yanked off a
sticky wall and I'm not even kidding
can we roll the video no I'm kidding we
don't I thought it best to talk in
pictures so I do something now I've
never ever done on a dirty job shoot
ever
I say timeout stop you guys know the
show we used take one we don't do take
two
there is no writing there's no scripting
there's no nonsense we don't fool around
we don't rehearse we shoot what we get I
said stop this is nuts
I mean you know what a Mississippi cue
this is crazy we can't do this you know
and Albert's like what and I'm like I
don't know what just happened but
they're testicles in this bucket and and
you know that's not how we do it he said
well that's how we do it and I see why
would you do it this way and before I
even let him explain I said I want to do
it the right way with the rubber bands
and he says like the Humane Society
I said yes like the Humane Society let's
do something that doesn't make the lamb
squeal and bleed we're on in five
continents dude we're on twice a day on
the Discovery we can't do this this is
okay he goes to his box and he pulls out
a bag of these little rubber bands
Melanie picks up another lamb puts it on
the post band goes on the tail band goes
on
scrotum lamb goes on the ground lamb
takes two steps falls down it gets up
shakes a little takes another couple
steps falls down I'm like this is not a
good sign for this land at all gets up
walks to the corner
it's quivering and it lies down and it's
in via stress and I'm I'm looking at the
lamb and I say Albert how long just you
know when's he get up it's like a day
today how long has it take him to fall
off a week meanwhile the lamb that he
had just did his little procedure on you
know he's just prancing around bleeding
stopped
he's you know nibbling on some grass
frolicking and I was just so blown away
at how completely wrong I was in that in
that second and I was reminded how
utterly wrong I am so much of the time
and I was especially reminded of how
what a ridiculously short straw I had
that day because now I had to do what
Albert had just done and they're like a
hundred of these lambs in the pen and
suddenly this whole thing's starting to
feel like a German porno and I'm like
Melanie picks up the lamp puts it on the
post opens it up Albert hands me the
knife I go in tail comes off I go in I
grab the scrotum tip it comes off
Albert instructs push it way up there I
do push it further I do the testicles
emerge they look like thumbs coming
right at you right and he says bite him
just just fight him off and I've heard
him I heard all the words
without it how did I get here how did I
mean how did I get here it's just one of
those moments where the brain goes you
know off on its own and suddenly I'm
standing there in the Rockies and all I
can think of is the Aristotelian
definition of a tragedy you know
Aristotle says the tragedy is that is
that moment when the hero comes
face-to-face with his true identity and
I'm like what something jacked up
metaphor I don't like what I'm thinking
right now and I don't know I can't get
this thought out of my head and I can't
get that vision out of my out of my
sight so I did what you know I had to do
I went in and I think oh my something
like this yanked my head back and I'm
standing there with two testicles on my
chin and now I can't get I can't shake
the metaphor okay I'm still in I'm still
in poetics and Aristotle and I'm
thinking out of nowhere two terms come
crashing into my head that I hadn't
heard since my classics professor in
college drilled them there and they are
anagnorisis in peripeteia
and AG noir assistant peripeteia
anagnorisis is the Greek word for
discovery literally the translation to
the transition from ignorance to
knowledge is anagnorisis it's what our
network does it's what dirty jobs is and
I'm up to my neck and I ignore seas
every single day
great the other word peripeteia
that's that that's the moment in the
great tragedies you know Euripides and
Sophocles that's the moment where
Oedipus has his moment where he suddenly
realizes that hot chick he's been
sleeping with and having babies with is
his mother okay that's pretty where
peripeteia and this metaphor in my head
I got an ignores and peripeteia on my
chin
I gotta tell you it's such a great
device though when you start to look for
peripeteia
you find it you find it everywhere unify
mean Bruce Willis in the sixth sense
right spends the whole movie trying to
help the little kid who sees dead people
and then BOOM
oh I'm dead peripeteia you know it's
it's it's it's crushing when the
audience sees it the right way neo in
the matrix you know oh I'm living in a
computer program that's weird you know
these discoveries that lead to sudden
realizations you know and I've been
having him over 230 jobs I have him all
the time but that one that one drilled
something home in a way that I just
wasn't prepared for and as I stood there
looking at the happy lamb that you know
I had just defiled but it looked okay
looking at that poor other little thing
that I'd done it the right way on it and
I just was struck by if I'm if I'm wrong
about if I'm wrong about that if I'm
wrong so often in a literal way
what other peripatetic misconceptions
might I be able to comment upon because
look I'm not a social anthropologist but
I have a friend who is and I I talked to
him and he says hey Mike look I mean I
don't know if your you know if your
brain is interested in this sort of
thing or not but do you realize you've
shot in every state you've worked in
mining you've worked in fishing you've
worked in steel you've worked in every
major industry you've you've had your
back shoulder to shoulder with these
guys that our politicians are desperate
to relate to every four years right I
can still see Hillary doing the shots a
ride dribbling down her chin with the
steelworkers I mean these are the people
that I work with every single day
and if you have something to say about
their thoughts collectively it might be
time to think about it because you know
for years so that's in my head testicles
are on my chin thoughts are bouncing
around and after that shoot Dirty Jobs
really didn't change in terms of what
the show is but it changed for me
personally and now when I talk about the
show I no longer just tell this
you heard and 190 like it I do but I
also start to talk about some of the
other things I got wrong some of the
other notions of work that I have just
been assuming our sacrosanct and they're
not people with dirty jobs are happier
than you think as a group they're the
happiest people I know and I don't want
to start whistling look for the union
label and all that happy worker crap I'm
just telling you that these are balanced
people who do unthinkable work
roadkill picker-uppers whistle while
they work I swear to god I did it with
them they've got this amazing sort of
symmetry to their life and I see it over
and over and over again so I started to
wonder what would happen if we
challenged some of these sacred cows
follow your passion
we've been talking about it here you
know for the last 36 hours
follow your passion what could possibly
be wrong with that it's probably the
worst advice I ever got you know you
know follow your dreams and go broke
right I mean that's all I heard growing
up I didn't know what to do with my life
but I was told if you follow your
passion it's gonna work out I can give
you 30 examples right now Bob combs the
pig farmer in Las Vegas who collects the
uneaten scraps of food from the casinos
and feeds them to his swine why because
there's so much protein and the stuff we
don't eat his pigs grow at twice the
normal speed and he is one rich pig
farmer and he is good for the
environment and he spends his days doing
this incredible service and he smells
like hell but god bless him he's making
a great living you ask him did you
follow your passion here he he'd laugh
at you you know the guy's worth
he just got offered like sixty million
dollars for his farm and turned it down
outside of Vegas he didn't follow his
passion he stepped back and he watched
where everybody was going and he went
the other way you know and I hear that
story over and over Matt Freund a dairy
farmer in New Canaan Connecticut who
woke up one day and realized the crap
from his cows was worth more than their
milk if he could use it to make these
biodegradable flower pots now he's
selling them to Walmart right he even
follow his passion the guys come on you
know so I started to look at passion I
started to look at efficiency versus if
stiffness as Tim talked about earlier
that's a huge distinction I started to
look at teamwork and determination and
basically all those platitudes they call
successor E's that hang with that
schmaltzy art in boardrooms around the
world right now that stuff it's suddenly
all been turned on its head safety
safety first is me going back to you
know OSHA and PETA and the Humane
Society you know what what if OSHA got
it wrong I mean I will this is heresy
what I'm about to say but what if what
if it's really safety third right
now I mean I mean really what I mean to
say is I value my safety on these crazy
jobs as much as the people that I'm
working with but the ones who really get
it done that they're not out there
talking about safety first they know
that other things come first the
business of doing the work comes first
the business of getting it done and you
know I'll never forget up in the Bering
Sea I was on a crab boat with The
Deadliest Catch guys which I which I
also work on in the first season we're
about a hundred miles off the coast of
Russia 50 foot seas big waves green
water coming over the wheelhouse right
most hazardous environment I'd ever seen
and I was back with a guy lashing the
pots down so I'm 40 feet off the deck
which is like looking down at the top of
your shoe you know and it's doing this
in the ocean unspeakably dangerous I
scamper down I go into the wheelhouse
and I say with some level of you know
incredulity captain OSHA and he says
OSHA ocean and he points out there and
but in that moment that what he said
next can't be repeated in the lower 48
it can't be repeated on the factory
floor any construction site but he
looked at me and he said son and he's my
age by the way he calls me son I love
that he says son I'm the captain of a
crab boat my responsibility is not to
get you home alive my responsibility is
to get you home rich you want to get
home alive that's on you and for the
rest of that day safety first
I mean I was like so you know the idea
that we create this this false the sense
of complacency when all we do is talk
about somebody else's responsibility as
though it's our own and vice versa
anyhow a whole lot of things I could
talk at length about the many little
distinctions we made in the endless list
of ways that I got it wrong but what it
all comes down to is this I have formed
a theory and I'm gonna share it now in
my remaining two minutes and 30 seconds
it goes like this
we've declared war on work as a society
all of us it's a civil war that's a cold
war really we didn't we didn't set out
to do it and we didn't twist our
mustache in some Machiavellian way but
we've done it and we have waged this war
on at least four fronts certainly in
Hollywood the way we portray working
people on TV it's laughable if there's a
plumber he's 300 pounds and he's got a
giant butt crack admit it you've seen
him all the time that's what plumbers
look like right we turn them into heroes
where we turn them into punchlines
that's what TV does we try hard on dirty
jobs not to do that which is why I do
the work and I don't cheat but we've
waged this war on Madison Avenue I mean
so many of the commercials that come out
there in the way of a message what's
really being said your life would be
better if you could work a little less
if you didn't have to work so hard if
you got home a little earlier if you
could retire a little faster if you
could punch out a little sooner it's all
it's all in there over and over again
and again Washington I can't even begin
to talk about the deals and policies in
place that affect the bottom line
reality of the available jobs because I
don't really know I just know that
that's a fun
in this war and right here guys Silicon
Valley I mean how many people have an
iPhone on them right now how many people
have their BlackBerry's on we're plugged
in we're connected I would never suggest
for a second that something bad has come
out of the tech revolution good grief
not to this crowd but I would suggest
that innovation without imitation
there's a complete waste of time and
nobody celebrates imitation the way
Dirty Jobs guys know it has to be done
your iPhone without those people making
the same interface the same circuitry
the same board over and over all that
you know that's what makes it equally as
possible is the genius that goes inside
of it so we've got this new toolbox
you know our tools today don't look like
shovels and picks they look like the
stuff we walk around with and so the
collective effect of all of that has
been this marginalization of lots and
lots of jobs and I realized you know
probably too late in this game I hope
not because I don't know if I can do 200
more of these things but we're gonna do
as many as we can and to me the most
important thing to know and to really
come face to face with is the fact that
I got it wrong about a lot of things not
just the testicles on my chin I got it I
got a lot wrong so we're thinking by we
I mean me that that the thing to do is
to talk about a PR campaign for work
manual labor
skilled labor somebody needs to be out
there talking about the Forgotten
benefits I'm talking about grandfather
stuff the stuff a lot of us probably
grew up with but we've kind of kind of
you know kind of lost a little barack
wants to create two and a half million
jobs the infrastructure is a huge deal
this war on work that I suppose exists
has casualties like any other war the
infrastructure is the first one
declining trade school enrollments are
the second one every single year fewer
electricians fewer carpenters fewer
plumbers fewer welders
were pipefitters fewer steamfitters the
infrastructure jobs that everybody is
talking about creating are those guys
the ones that have been in decline over
and over meanwhile we got two trillion
dollars at a minimum according to the
American Society of Civil Engineers that
we need to expand to even make a dent in
the infrastructure which is currently
rated at a d-minus so if I were running
for anything and I'm not I would simply
say that the jobs we hope to make and
the jobs we hope to create aren't gonna
stick unless they're jobs that people
want and I know the point of this
conference is to celebrate things that
are near and dear to us but I also know
that clean and dirty aren't opposites
there are two sides of the same coin
just like innovation and imitation like
risk and responsibility like peripeteia
and a diagnosis like that poor little
lamb who I hope isn't quivering anymore
and like my time that's gone it's been
great talking to you and get back to
work
[Applause]